[Music]
hello and welcome to i'd like to know
this is our question and answer program
our bible question and answer program
this is a program where we like to go
into the word of god answer your
questions find answers if answers can
indeed be found sometimes we find an
answer and then we find more information
after the program is over but that's
always fun also my name is c.a murray
i'm in the company of our speaker
director
pastor stephen bohr and
we are happy to be here and
i know he's happy to be here always
[Laughter]
we have a good time on this program as
you can no doubt see my sister said to
me the other day she said you know i i
watch your program it looks like you and
the pastor actually like each other and
i will i will tell you a secret
it's true
we do like each other we like each other
a lot we get along together well and
anytime you you draw close to christ you
draw closer to your brothers and sisters
right and and we see so much of the word
of god alike
we are like in many ways uh far too many
to to let you in on but we are
and um uh we have a good time together
the working relationship here at secret
sun seal is a beautiful one everybody
gets along and this is the kind of place
when somebody makes a mistake they are
quick to say i'm sorry and press on
together and that's a good place it's a
good working atmosphere so
giving all that behind the scenes stuff
we want to answer your questions
we invite you to become part of the
program i've got a little pile here he
has a much larger one on his desk from
which we try to mine questions each and
every week but if you'd like to send in
a question
you can email us at tv at some tv.org
that's tv
at some tv dot o r g and we will do our
very best to answer your questions
pastor before we get started would you
please lead us in prayer yes let's pray
father in heaven we come before your
awesome throne
in the powerful name of jesus
there are so many questions that we have
many of which will be answered only in
eternity by jesus
but in this program we ask that you will
be with us enlighten us
as we try to answer these questions that
have been sent in
we ask for the guidance of your spirit
for your heavenly wisdom amen and we
thank you lord for hearing our prayer we
ask it in jesus name amen amen and amen
when last we were together pastor we
touched on a question i don't know if we
dealt with it thoroughly
someone asked a question about dancing
and
perhaps we ought to tidy that up a
little bit before we go into our new
material but do you have anything else
to add to to what we touched on just i
think it was last week yeah
one of the
stories that the bible has that people
use to defend dancing
is they say well david danced
and it's true that the word dance is
used for david but there are several
things that we need to take into account
first of all
god did not command him to dance
it was kind of like a momentary reaction
on his part
because the ark of the covenant was
coming back to jerusalem
and so it was a specific historical
occasion that led him probably we should
say to jump for joy
and from what we understand it was
closer to jumping for joy than the kind
of stuff we see today yes yeah and it
was so low yes in other words there's no
there's no way that you can defend good
point romantic dancing yes you know
chest to chest
with this story because he's dancing by
himself or he's jumping for joy by
himself
in a specific historical event the
coming of uh the ark of the covenant to
jerusalem and also the fact that he was
not commanded to do it it's a
spontaneous thing that he did the bible
mentions many things that people did
where there's no moral evaluation and
what they did whether it's right or
wrong good point so we need we can't
just take a story from the bible and say
well because david did it uh we're
justified in doing it
romantically if you please
the bible touches on
god's interface with man
the good the bad and the ugly everything
the bible talks about is not sanctioned
by god some things we may get to someone
a little bit later are specifically not
sanctioned by god but it mentions it all
and of course these things were given as
examples for us so it was a spontaneous
reaction you remember 20 years earlier
when the ark was taken eli dodd hofney
died phineas died
wife died in childbirth you know ichabod
was born at what they called the
chattahood so you know it was a sad day
and now it's back so that's a great day
so in in response to
a once-in-a-lifetime occasion yeah
he leaves for joy you can't make a
gospel doctrine out of that that's right
yeah and
you know furthermore
david's dance
in the streets of jerusalem
was what awakened the jealousy
in the heart of saul yes
because the women started saying you
know
saul has killed his thousands and david
has killed his ten thousands yeah yeah
so uh you know the the end result
of his jumping for joy or for whatever
it was
uh led to uh saul developing jealousy
not not to uh justify soul for that
right but uh it's interesting to see
that what the consequence was yeah and
another person wasn't so happy at what
he'd done was his wife michael uh saul's
daughter she was not pleased at all uh
so we're talking about a one-time thing
and again one of the things we mentioned
last time when we mentioned is that if
you're going to get to the point where
you're a professional dancer uh and
dancing in competitions and those kind
of things and i think that was the the
the thought that was underlying the
question you got to put in a lot of time
you know you can't you can't just you
got to put in time and that is time that
can be better used i suspect doing the
work of the lord or uh studying to show
thyself approved or
witnessing to your neighbor there's so
many other things you can do for the
cause of christ in the time the
considerable amount of time that you
would use to bone upon dancing you can
use that time perhaps better doing
something for the cause of christ not
only time but money oh yes
[Laughter]
okay now we have another question
this one somebody first of all comments
that
let's see
this person is a new adventist
and they're thankful for our programs
here at secrets unsealed and then comes
the question
my pastor was preaching in my church and
he said when jesus was born to this
earth
he was blank about his godly nature in
other words he didn't know about his
pre-existent
pre-existence he said he was fully human
which i agree
but also he said he didn't know about
this pre-existence in heaven
when he was on earth
and he learned everything from his
mother how truthful is that in other
words when did jesus become aware
that he was not a mere human being and
he had the divine mission
to save the human race
was it at birth was it you know later on
was it when he went to the cross
we split the difference one of the
things we see in the desire of aid is
ellen white talks about his first trip
to the temple as a young man in that
12th year
as he went into the temple
he looked at the white robe priest she
says he looked at the sacrifices he
looked at the the prayers being offered
he looked at all the things that were
going on and he had this awakening
that he was somehow involved and tied up
in all of this
and as he
looked and
understood
he lingered in fact he spent a couple
days there before his parents found that
he had left him behind but that seemed
to be the time when it fully
dawned on him that he was tied up in
that mission that the sacrifices of the
of the temple were going to be
sacrifices that that he was going to
make that his life was tied up with that
so that's the first time we get a true
understanding that he understood
specifically what his mission was and
that he was central to all that was
going on in the temple
in desire of ages we have this very
interesting statement this is page 78
the first visit of jesus to the temple
his bar mitzvah yes
yes
because every male 12 years and older
had to come to jerusalem yes for certain
feasts and passover was one of them yes
for the first time the child jesus
looked upon the temple
he saw the white robe priests
arming their performing their solemn
ministry
he beheld the bleeding victim upon the
altar of sacrifice
with the worshipers he bowed in prayer
while the cloud of incense ascended
before god
he witnessed the impressive rites of the
paschal service
day by day
because this is several days that he
spent there
day by day he saw their meaning more
clearly
every act
seemed to be bound up with his own life
yes
new impulses were awakening within him
silent and absorbed
he seemed to be studying out a great
problem yes the mystery of his mission
was opening to the savior yeah i am sure
that mary as a diligent mother as most
all jewish mothers did
taught her son about the coming messiah
taught her son about the the desire of
ages but
he didn't
enter into that fully until that day
when he saw what was going on and
realized that that was him that was part
of his life part of his existence
and and i don't think that his mother
fully realized
what kind of messiah he was i agree you
know it kind of dawned on her as time
went by
but you know there's an episode in the
gospel of mark
that indicates that she did not fully
understand what the mission of jesus was
this is in mark chapter 3
beginning with verse 33
it says here actually a little bit
earlier than that
um verse 31 to verse 35
it says and his mother and his brothers
arrived
standing outside
they sent word to him and called him and
of course
jesus had been working
so hard for so long
that they thought that he was maybe
losing it a little bit and so they come
to take him home
and it says in verse 32 and a multitude
was sitting around him and they said to
him behold your mother and your brothers
are outside looking for you
and answering them he said
who are my mother and my brothers
and looking about on those who were
sitting around him he said behold my
mother and my brothers for whoever does
the will of god he is my brother and
sister and mother and you know we know
that at the temple
jesus knew that joseph was not his real
father because he said i am about my
father's business yes he was talking
about his heavenly father so he realized
that his paternity was actually from
heaven yeah he he knew a lot of things
because the the people questioning him
asked how how does this guy know all of
this stuff having never been taught well
we never taught him what they're saying
but he had learned it uh at his mother's
knee and of course over the last several
days of this experience he was picking
up new clues and and and understanding
the context for all of this stuff they
hadn't taught him but he knew he knew
who he was and he knew what he was about
at that time what's interesting
you know pastor you look at a person who
went through so much of his life having
no one to really enter into the secret
understanding of what he was here for
john the baptist ellen white tells us as
as greater prophet as he was he didn't
understand christ's mission you know he
didn't understand the disciples didn't
understand until very very very late um
really if you look at it until after he
had he had passed uh
passed on to heaven
there were very very few who had an
intimate understanding of what jesus was
about it must be really tough to go
through life and have nobody to be able
to truly understand your mission and
what you're about so if you're
misunderstood you're in good company
you're in good company indeed i noticed
that you had i kind of peeked at your
notes uh you had some verses written
down about the encounter of jesus with
the uh with the priests
and the intelligentsia uh actually no
these these are notes for another
question uh that that that uh hopefully
we will get to um
let me see
i think it's in luke chapter two if i'm
not mistaken
uh where it speaks about his visit to
jerusalem
uh this is found in luke chapter two
beginning with verse 41
but but it's interesting here uh to read
the description of his encounter with
the teachers yes the rabbis yes it says
in luke chapter 2 and verse
45 when the parents come back looking
for jesus
and when they did not find him they
returned to jerusalem looking for him
and when it came about that after three
days they found him in the temple yes
sitting in the midst of the teachers
[Music]
[Laughter]
both listen carefully both listening to
them yes
and asking them questions
and then verse 47 says and all who heard
in this 12 year old kid
and all who heard him were amazed at his
understanding
and his
answers
so they were asking jesus questions and
jesus was shooting back the answers and
they were amazed and then asking them
questions that they were struggling
that someone uh his age who had never
studied in the schools of the rabbis
precisely knew how
as much as he did to ask to ask a good
question you've got to have information
so he's posing questions that's testing
their knowledge answering their
questions so yeah their mouths are open
because
where does this kid get this stuff from
he's only 12 years old and we never
taught him ellen white mentions that
one thing that he talked to the
religious leaders about was isaiah 53.
basically the idea was you believe that
the messiah is going to come he's going
to sit on the throne of david and he's
going to rule with a rod of iron but
what do we do with isaiah 53 the
suffering servant whereas
that is killed yes
and of course they're
interesting yeah then a young child
would ask this kind of question by the
way this also shows that mary
instructed jesus fully in the scriptures
yes yes because he was able to argue
from the scriptures so on her knee ellen
white says yes that she taught jesus to
respect and to understand the old
testament scriptures and praise the lord
for that
amen and amen
okay now here we have another one
and this one deals with matthew 24 15 so
maybe we can go there to matthew 24 and
verse 15.
of course this is a chapter that speaks
about the signs
of the soon coming of christ
and in chapter 24
and verse 15
do you have that there pastor i'm going
to
admit something to you
i'm a slave of technology sometimes my
ipad which has several bibles on it has
just died oh it has i'm pressing the
button and it's telling me nope i'm not
coming back i'm dead so you're a slave
to technology but technology is not a
slave to you precisely
it has a mind of its own and and i
always come to my bible but i said oh i
got my ipad today i'll be okay that's
all right that's all right
um
we got to go by what's in the book amen
one way or the other
okay this is matthew 24 verse 15.
the question is about the abomination of
this desolation
therefore when you see the abomination
of desolation which was spoken of
through daniel the prophet
standing in the holy place
and then in parentheses let the reader
understand
then let those who are in judea flee to
the mountains
so the question is
in matthew 24 15 what is the abomination
that causes desolation and where is the
holy place well
let's compare
the parallel passage in luke 21
in luke chapter 21
and it appears to be totally different
i mean like
no relationship with what we just read
in matthew
because in matthew it says when you see
the abomination of desolation spoken up
by daniel
but in luke 21 and verse 20
it says
but when you see jerusalem surrounded by
armies
then recognize that her desolation is at
hand
and then the next verse says then those
who own judea flee
so the abomination of desolation is
related to the roman army surrounded
jerusalem
now the question is
what did the armies have
that was an abomination
well in the book great controversy page
ellen white wrote
uh the following uh words which by the
way not only defined the abomination of
desolation as it applies to literal
jerusalem but it also answers the
question as to where the holy spirit the
holy place says yes
it says do you have it there by any
chance i do not quotation okay when the
idolatrous standards of the romans
now let's stop there for a minute
we know from josephus
that when the romans surrounded a city
and besieged it
that they would take their standards and
they would nail the standards in the
ground
and then they would kneel and they would
render worship to their standards
[Music]
now their standards contained an eagle
without stretched wings and a sun burst
around the eagle or a golden
wreath around the eagle which
represented the orb of the sun yes in
other words they were worshiping the sun
god mithra which had been adopted by the
roman legions in the year 63 b.c
and and so what they would do is they
would surround the city and then they
would nail their
standards in the ground and they would
kneel and render worship to the sun god
that's why all white states when the
idolatrous standards of the romans
should be set up in the holy place now
here's the holy place
which extended some furlongs outside the
city walls
so there was an area outside the city
walls that was considered holy holy not
only the new jersey not only jerusalem
and so it says when the idolatrous
standards of the romans should be set up
in the holy ground which extended some
furlongs outside the city walls
then the followers of christ were to
find safety in flight
when the warning signs should be seen
those who would escape must make no
delay
but of course here's the question that i
want to throw out
how could they
escape the city
if the city was surrounded and besieged
well maybe there was a time when it
wasn't surrounded or besieged maybe
there was a little interim in there yes
when the romans weren't there and the
call was given uh to go at that at that
time and it's interesting to see the way
in which that interim took place yes
the in the year 66 cestius gallus
who was the
general of the armies at that time
besieged jerusalem
and when it looked like the city was
going to fall for sure
suddenly something miraculous happened
we know the reason why
but the roman legions
under the leadership of cestius
picked up camp and fled and left
yeah and the jews who were inside the
city particularly the false prophets who
were saying this is god's city it's
going to abide forever it's never going
to fall
they saw the roman legions flee they
said god is with us we told you and so
many of the jews inside the city went
after the roman legions and the roman
legion suffered many many losses yes
many of their soldiers were killed
and so
when the christians in the city saw
the romans put their uh standards in the
ground and render them worship
they knew they couldn't flee at that
moment but when they saw cestius and the
roman legions leave they said
that was the sign this is our shot and
ellen white states in great controversy
that not one christian perished yes in
the destruction of jerusalem because
they had seen the sign yeah now when
they came back under was it titus titus
under titus uh and of course titus later
became a member when they they came back
they finished the work i mean they came
back for business and they destroyed
everything and then four years later at
masada
flavius silva
took care of the last remnants so
those who listened to christ who
listened to the word were saved those
who did not and listen to the false
prophets were lost and that
scenario is going to be repeated yes
right until the river
euphrates dries up here at the end of
time
there will be those who will be
listening to the word who will be led by
the word others listening to false
prophets who will be lost
interestingly enough ellen white makes
an end time application because matthew
24 has a two-fold application oh yes it
applies in a limited way to the events
that led up to this destruction of
jerusalem but it also has an end time
global fulfillment yes and she has a
couple of statements where she compares
the roman legions
worshiping their sun standards and
worship on the day of the sun at the end
of time which is the sign for god's the
last opportunity for god's people to
leave the large cities preparatory to
leave those leave the smaller ones and
then flee yeah so it has two
applications
okay very good any other
things that we need to say about that i
think we've put a bow on that pretty
well
as far as the abomination that causes
desolation
okay now we have one more we only have
like four a little more than four
minutes left ellen white has made
several pointed statements on how god
is was and is against polygamy stating
that it was one of the chief reasons for
the flood
why then would god so silently why was
god so silently and different
to people he chose to work with
practicing this sin it mentions abraham
jacob samuel's father david who were
polygamous
instead of first asking them to repent
of it and put it away
especially when it was done after god
had elected them and he strictly did for
other sins
god even actually looked it over
in his law even quasi regulating it
rather than the bad then ban it outright
so the first thing that i want to say
uh is that
ellen white states that the
biggest reason for the flood
was the amalgamation of the sons of god
with the daughters of men it was not
primarily polygamy
it was really
the
intermingling of the sons of god which
represents the righteous and the
daughters of men
three of which were in the genealogy of
cain
that actually
brought corruption to the world and
brought about the flood yes it was not
polygamy was not the
major sin that led to the flood well
said but what else can we say about
polygamy well i've got a quote from
patriots and prophets page 38 polygamy
was practiced at an early date so man
had been doing it a long time it was one
of the sins that brought the wrath of
god upon the anteluvian world so god was
not ignorant of it and it was one of
those did not one of the things right
yet after the flood it again became
widespread it was satan's studied effort
to pervert the marriage institution to
weaken its obligations and lessen its
sacredness for in no sure way could he
deface the image of god in man and open
the door to misery and vice so it was
one of the sins it was it was one of the
things that that was responsible for
god's reaction against
against humanity that and
as you well stated the the amalgamation
uh point being that you know the bible
says when god does not swiftly react to
things when he does not swiftly punish
sin man is emboldened in his sin so you
take a little step
the sky doesn't fall you take another
big step pretty soon you're running down
that lane because you don't think uh
judgment will ever come
but it does come and more than that the
the condition of the world
under uh these kinds of things
deteriorated and deteriorated and
deteriorated and man began to destroy
his own world and his relationship with
the lord because of this practice and
other practices at that time and the
bottom line is that in
culture at that time
this
practice of polygamy was entrenched in
society
and you know god sometimes allows time
to pass like for slavery for example
you look at the new testament the new
testament doesn't denounce slavery but
it gives principles
to that eventually would lead to the
abolition of slavery yes
so god knows that sometimes it's not
best to confront something head-on
unless it's a matter of a
definite principle
because he knows that eventually in the
course of time
people will be enlightened and they'll
understand yes uh that god's way is the
best way and sometimes people don't
understand why are we suffering why are
we going through all this it's because
you're not following the way of god
god's rules are not arbitrary uh they
are for our own good and when we refuse
to obey them we suffer we make ourselves
to suffer yeah even today
people
are not allowed to be polygamous at
least in the united states of america
and
i think jesus is the is the main
standard when we come to this and in
matthew chapter 19 he says he who made
them in the beginning made male and
female and he said to the man to uh join
his wife not his wives so jesus is the
authority well our time is up thank you
for joining us god bless you hope to see
you next time and i'd like to know
[Music]
you